[Music]
what's going on guys
the leaves are turning pumpkin spice
lattes are back so that means one thing
it's fall movie season and we've got an
awesome crew of critics to talk about it
with you know this guy he is my
biological father and he's my host of
movie review talk on Collider Scott
mance she's a friend of screen junkies
you've seen her on movie fights and all
over the place she's the film critic for
pajama Joelle Monique and she is one of
the hosts of FX movie download Sasha
pearl raver yeah this has got a little
bit of everything and this is what a lot
of Oscar bait comes out so I'm excited
because we yeah it's a nice mess baby
like it's a bad thing no good thing I
was most excitingly we have a Ryan
Gosling movie that is also a Damien
Chazelle movie you know you brought it
up let's talk about it
so what are we hearing has anyone seen
first man first action um I thought that
this movie was one of the most visually
spectacular things I've seen in a really
long time it is
so visceral tangible beautifully acted I
mean this is not like any other movie
about the space race that you've seen
before it's almost like a procedural
about about the Apollo 11 mission thatwe
are on the moon in July of 1969 but what
makes this movie so unique is you don't
just see the space race you feel it good
you know you got me I'm looking forward
to it even more now okay one movie I am
so excited the trailer has taken me away
to a magical place Mary Poppins
love to hear just your initial thought
time you what have you seen a very
powerful just just like you guys assists
in of just film loving culture yes like
lin-manuel Miranda has cast such a spell
on like all of us that mix of animation
and the visuals was so it just kind of
exploded over everybody they were like
this is so new and they were able to
match that just in the little things
we've seen so far to bring that magic in
that life I've been very critical of a
lot of the Disney live-action movies
lately especially the stuff they're
doing for their classic animation line
this got me excited this brought me back
in so I'm excited to see what they do
with this yeah I must say about Mary
Poppins returns because first of all
Emily Blunt she could do no wrong she
could be in a very enviable position a
good problem to have here she could be
competing against herself at the Oscars
with Mary Poppins returns and one of my
favorite movies if not my favorite movie
of the year so far which is a quiet
place there's so much to recommend that
there's so much to get excited for see
it with someone you care enough okay
okay so here's a movie that a lot of
people are excited about I know Sasha is
half and half out on it venom so my
feeling on that yeah hi reminds me of
the market web spider fine be back
before we started was talking about this
and she said she knew everything she
knew about this movie by the fact that
it's pg-13 oh yeah what does that say to
you that it's cheap know that it's pg-13
for that hard we know our tickets are
hard to sell because you can children
can't just walk into the Deadpool
Deadpool sold and they have that marker
to base it off of so the fact that they
were like we're not gonna do Deadpool
sales we need to go pg-13 as to me that
the studio doesn't have a confidence
behind you do we know that were they
considering going r with venom when they
first and now it's pre-production yeah
they were wavering back and forth gotcha
all right it's pg-13
he's not gonna be as badass but it is
Tom Hardy it starts it by Ruben
Fleischer who did zombie land I mean
it's I expect a fun movie you cannot
have venom without spider-man that's my
only concern
well I'm hoping for
venom and guess what guess who's back a
little more JK Rowling fantastic beasts
yeah
the first vid that fit beast did not do
it for me that reveal twisted the end
was so disheartening when we never have
a perfect villain and they're like
surprise it's JJ you're like oh okay so
but my guess is they've learned a lot
from their mistakes Warner Brothers is
not going to be fooling around with
their top property so I'm excited for it
I love all the source material from it
as far as just nukes commanders journey
so I'm excited to see what they do all
eight Harry Potter movies are great the
third one the president of Azkaban was
the best one but fantastic Bors and
where to sleep the first move Wow so
acceptable fantastic naps and where to
[Applause]
[Music]
dream you guys argue I mean big selling
point is Johnny Depp that's not gonna
get my button Aziz
yeah personally yes to the thing that
I'm really excited from from Warner
Brothers is a star is born
oh yeah yeah and just that trailer
oh man that movie is generating so much
excitement just and every like I want to
see you like well you saw what I saw and
this is the reimagined version this
retelling of this classic story hits all
the beats if you've never seen the other
versions you're really really really
gonna love this movie you're not gonna
know where it's going if you've seen any
one of the other versions you will know
where that's good because the movie is
going and that's the problem is that it
doesn't take any chances to sort of
break out and do something completely
different
having said that Bradley Cooper who
stars in this movie Oscar for master
actor will he win will he win no you
don't think so don't get I think he'll I
think it's a very good shot at getting
nominated Eastwood Redford Warren Beatty
they love congratulating actors who make
the crossover I don't know I could see
there he might not win but he's
definitely good I think it's a very good
shot of getting on the bull he win i TBD
we shall see so Joelle you and I were
talking a little bit you were up in tiff
yeah Toronto International Film Festival
and you you saw widows that trailer got
me a little bit excited so Jeff talk to
me first 15 seconds yeah I like the
first 15 seconds are like a gunshot what
is happening that all that energy is
infused here and then you combine that
with Steve McQueen's visual I know
spoilers here but there is a great plot
twist in this movie another big movie
that I'm looking forward to Creed to who
knew that creep was gonna be I mean
here's a spinoff of Rocky but that was
the best Rocky
esque movie since the original rocky
because it was a return to form of his
return to the roots it was gritty I'm
excited that Ryan's stepping back and
giving another black director an
opportunity to shine so I'm excited to
see what they do in the direction that
creature goes in Oh another movie that
I'm really looking forward to Scott
mattes I know you are a huge classic
rock fan yep bohemian rap song I can't
wait for this movie yeah I have not seen
it yet rami malek just looks fantastic
as Freddy Mercury the only problem is
that there was some problem by the
scenes Brian singer directed all but the
last two weeks of the movie he kind of
like stepped away and and someone else
came in to finish off the film not good
when that happens on a big-budget movie
bite from I'm excited about Bohemian
Rhapsody ladies what do you think
Rami malik shows up i will be there
you know what he does and if he's
passionate about a role you know he's
gonna be bringing a lot of attention to
it so I'm excited but I'm apprehensive
about how much I'm gonna enjoy it the
things I've seen it looks pretty good
but I don't know it's hard for me to
judge where I'm at with the film so far
I think it's interesting that every
single person on this couch is
pronouncing rami malek same and
different why I think that's really I'm
just saying I love him I walked down the
aisle a wedding to Queen like I love
Queen I'm very excited for this film I
think the music is gonna be fantastic
the performance are gonna be fantastic
okay this movie looks intense from the
director of moonlight if Beale Street
could talk the film itself is so good
the crux of the story is a woman becomes
pregnant by her fiance who was then
imprisoned immediately after and her
goal is to get him out of prison before
the baby comes
that's the entire story the fact is you
could take the story and place it almost
over almost any time period in America
and it would play exactly the same way
sort of the heartbreaking aspect of it
Brian Tiger Henry Colman Domingo and
Keanu parish could all see Supporting
Actor roles nominations for this and
Regina King stunning sunny performance
is beautifully beautifully shot it's
just an excellent film front to back
yeah I love Regina King I was so happy
to see her win an Emmy Award recently
she's like she's one of those unsung
women has just been crushing it great
memories but you get the awards
attention that she deserves shoot cool
down let's let's start web-swinging in
the animated space a spider-man into the
spider-verse got a brand new spider-man
that we haven't seen before on the big
Skrull yes
I wish they were doing this is a
live-action movie I think animated films
don't get to do enough like people
talked about there's so many properties
people talking about like oh it needs a
movie
things like Sandman which would be
better as an animated film than a
live-action
I think comic book heroes they make
really great live-action pop one but
we're limited and Howard what were able
to do physically in the real world but
in comics there are no limitations like
we go anywhere and do anything
exactly boy erased boy erased looks so
unbelievable but I don't know that I can
sit through the film joel edgerton who
did such a brilliant job directing the
gift
now he's written and directed this film
and it's about a family played by Nicole
Kidman and trying to get their son Lucas
hedges conversion therapy yeah game
conversion therapy when I watch the
trailer
I am so disturbed by it I'm so upset I'm
so moved I don't know that I can sit
through I can barely get through two and
a half minutes I don't know that I can
get through two hours yeah heartbreaking
subject matter Micah's hedges who was an
Oscar nominee for Manchester by the sea
yeah it's gonna be an Oscar nominee
again for bully erased and you know else
is gonna get nominated Nicole Kidman and
Russell Crowe it's like it's the best
thing he has done in years talk to us
about beautiful boy
it's about addiction addiction stories
anybody who's watched sharp objects well
you're watching this character that
she's being eaten alive by their
addiction and the people who love them
played so brilliantly not just by Steve
Carell also Amy Ryan Amy Ryan who was
always undervalue yeah yeah appreciated
she is off the charts the movie is so
absorbing the characters are tangible
and feel like somebody who you know
somebody who you care about going
through that film especially with Steve
Carell who we have come to know and
we've watched on screen for so long
breaks your heart moment by moment you
want him to adopt you by the end of the
film you feel like when you walk out of
the theater you're leaving it feels like
when you walk out from like a long visit
at Christmas and then you're going home
to your own house all right talk to me
about Rafiki yes okay so I saw her
sneaky it's North American premiere it
is so beautiful but I'm really I'm just
starting to get into films coming out
all over Africa um mostly we know films
out of Nollywood this one is out of
Ethiopia female director over 40 it's a
LGBTQ film it was banned in its home
country until like four days ago
the director went back home and
challenged their constitution and said I
have a right to screen this movie it's
gorgeous work if you're into films that
are have a lot of heart and that aren't
going to beat you over the head with a
message this is a film for you Rafiki is
gorgeous it means friends very cool
Suspiria oh Suspiria i want to see so
it's got all of these like flesh and
bone Black Swan vibes and I mean all of
that yeah we're hearing great things
about it I don't know what to think but
it was such an experience and those
movies are right up my alley so I can't
wait Scott okay two two movies that I
have to touch on one of them was Roma
and this is written and directed by
Alfonso Cuaron yeah this is a black and
white movie with no score about a
diligent servant tending to a family
that's coming apart at the seams in
Mexico City Best Lead Actress
Aparicio that she did bang out job and
just she steals your heart by the end of
the film and the other thing the other
movie we have to bring up to is Green
Book which is a film that won the
Audience Award at the Toronto Film
Festival where justice directed by Peter
family yeah oh wow after the family
brothers that Dumber yeah Wow
it should definitely be on the radar you
guys I have to say you got me so excited
now because of the fall I'm excited for
sweater and hoodie weather yeah and all
of these movies Wow what movie are you
most excited about let us know in the
comments section below
was there anything that we didn't
mention tell us tell us why you're
excited about it Scott Matz Joelle
Monique
Sasha pearl raver you guys broke it down
you brought so much knowledge today I am
so thankful and I'm sure our audience is
thankful I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies please follow us
all on Twitter's and instagrams and all
good stuff and we'll see you next time
[Music]